100 is what percent of 80 and these
problems tend to kill people because on
some level they're kind of simple
there's just 180 there and they're
asking what percent but then people get
confused they say do I divide 100 by the
80 to 80 by 100 or is it something else
going on and you really just have to
think through what the language is
saying they're saying that this value
right here this hundred is some
percentage of 80 and that some
percentage is what we have to figure out
that what percent so if we multiply 80
by this what percent we will get a
hundred so let's view it this way we
start we have 80 we have 80 if we
multiply it by something let's call this
something X if we multiply let me do
that in a different color if we multiply
80 by something we are going to get 100
and we need to figure out what we need
to multiply 80 by to get 100 and if we
just solve this equation as it is we're
going to get a a value for x and what we
need to do is then convert it to a
percent another way you could view this
is you know 100 is what you get when you
multiply what by 80 and then you would
have gotten this number and then you
could convert it to a percent so this is
essentially the equation and now we can
solve it if we divide both sides of this
equation by 80 so you divide the
left-hand side by 80 the right-hand side
by 80 you get X X is equal to 100 over
80 you could divide well one they both
share a common factor of 20 so 100
divided by 20 is 5 is 5 and 80 divided
by 20 is 4 so in simplest form X is
equal to 5/4 but I've only expressed it
as a fraction but they want to know what
percent of 80 if they just said 100 is
what fraction of 80 we would be done we
could say 100 is 5/4 of 80 and we would
be absolutely correct but they want to
say what percent so we have to convert
this to a percent and the easiest thing
to do is to first convert it into a
decimal so let's do that 5 over 4 is
literally this is literally the same
thing as
5/4 so let's figure out what that is let
me do it in magenta so 5 divided by 4 5
divided by 4 and we want to have all the
decimals there so let's put some zeroes
out here 4 goes into 5 one time let me
switch up the colors one time 1 times 4
is 4 you subtract you get 5 minus 4 is 1
bring down the next zero and of course
the decimal sitting right here so we
want to put it right over there
so you bring down the next zero you
bring down the next zero 4 goes into 10
two times two times four is eight
you subtract 10 minus 8 is 2 bring down
the next zero bring down the next zero 4
goes into 20 five times 5 times 4 is 20
subtract no remainder so this is exactly
this is equal to one point two five five
over 4 is the same thing as five divided
by four which is equal to one point two
five so so far we could say 100 is one
point two five times 80 or one point two
five of 80 you could even say it but we
still haven't expressed it as a
percentage this is really just as a as a
number as a as a su could call it as a
decimal but it's all it's a whole number
and a decimal so it would be a mixed
number if we didn't do it as a decimal
it's 1 and 1/4 or 1 and 25 hundredths
however you want to read it so to write
it as a percent you literally just have
to multiply this times 100 or shift the
decimal over twice so this is going to
be equal to as a percent if you just
shift the decimal over twice this is
equal to 125 125 percent let me not
write it out 125 per cent and that makes
complete sense 100 is 125 percent of 80
80 is 100 percent of 80 100 percent is
more than 80 it's actually 1 in 1/4 of
80 and you see that right over there so
it makes sense it's 125 percent
more than a hundred percent but we are
done we've solved the problem it is one
hundred and twenty five percent of 80